okay I heard
you have a whole project with gonna yeah
yeah I got a whole project we got that
but the people all right so Lee was
supposed shout out to my guy Lee
Foundation Foundation immediately was
supposed to put the money up for the
project right but it's already recorded
it's all done and all that and it is not
even and this is like two years old
right that's clear yeah you're real
tight with two years YSL yeah oh YSL so
yeah me and Gunner specifically like
we're closer not closer than Thug but
like we are on the same level as how I
am with Doug like because Thug grew up
with us basically before when I was in
Atlanta PeeWee Longway we all grew up
from 18 well when I was 18. so uh
I got that relationship whatever I come
home and he like look I'm a executive
producer project your first project just
like we're gonna say that yeah yeah he's
like that's how you gonna get a bag
that's what he told me it's how you're
gonna go get the bag tell them how much
they could do it and they go and he like
I got you get it there so we do it we
record he's only on three songs of the
project pretty executive producer yeah
and then I had Dirk on the project I got
all type of like I might have to some of
these songs on my phone actually yeah
you do guys
yeah you got you guys up most of the
songs and it was like all right I'm
dropping I'm dropping then I just
dropped and I went through a whole lot
and people wasn't seeing it because it
was off camera like when I dropped not
enough I had a whole rollout I got
distros begging me to finish like like
you keep dropping right but I went
through recently and it just like it
kind of like
it was like ripping the rap up out of me
like and then it's like I'm reaching out
to rap like my rap friends in the middle
of that trying to keep the rap going on
to you know I mean and it's like
everybody not even when I mean my rap
friend not even the ones that's doing
the rapping it's like the producers is
is right the background folks yeah this
dude video engineer me yeah I mean like
like that it's just like the dots ain't
connected so I just said I'm good at so
you decided
to just leave rap alone for now for
those months I'm back but I had to yeah
I had to clear my mind because it was
like if it frustrated me anymore while
I'm going through this and like because
what how long were you locked up three
years uh three and a half the last time
right yeah
because you had the YG record it was
u-y-g-i-a-d yeah and then I had just
dropped with Chris Brown right after
that and then you ended up locked up
yeah so it was like a bad it was
terrible because you obviously get close
with Chris Brown from that kid ink tour
with fetty WAP right yeah well no I was
cool with Chris
I just was talking about that yeah it
was crazy uh
French Montana French was on it yeah
because French was he was coming out
with Chris yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I was actually that tour might have
ended our friendship more than you and
Chris's yeah oh wow
I have no idea that's when he was like
running around with like every blood in
L.A on tour yeah Menace and everybody
was there what was that guy's name kid
red kid red yeah yeah so I don't know
what the [__] happened yeah Manish was
joining the tour yeah Compton Menace was
the first guy to open the face it was
the first dude yeah yeah it went Compton
Tiana and it went the Migos it was a
very random tour and it was a whole lot
of controversy behind that line who was
opening whoa cause I remember Kid Ink
went on after the Migos and at that time
I was like I don't know
Omarion went on after Kid Ink and it
didn't make sense no no no did he go on
I think Omarion went on after Kid Ink
there was something involving ink where
it just Omarion with oh no kid ink was
right behind Chris Chris oh so did
Omarion think he should be yeah he got
over that because of the hits or
whatever the case was but Omarion was at
the half I think he wasn't really
tripping tripping like I don't want to
piss now that's what it was because I
remember hearing about it all right so
this I went it went uh
I think he had to go before fetty WAP
he had to go before fetty WAP like fetty
WAP knew and I wasn't doing Chris like
this when when they was going on tour
with us did ink go on after fetty wiper
before
he went on after fetty that's who I'm
thinking there's just no way at that
time yeah yeah it was it was a big homie
move you kind of know at that time
Chris Brown still Chris Brown one of the
greatest entertainers we've ever had
lived but I was on the radio side giving
away tickets to that that tour
and listeners were calling in and they
weren't saying I want Chris Brown
tickets they were saying I want fetty
WAP tickets because that was when fetty
WAP was it was a bit yeah it was and it
was fetty WAP he's so humble he was
paying his respect he didn't even yeah
because he just was like like I think
people understand the 2014-15 fetty WAP
run he was crazy that's what I'm like
you go out there and when he goes out
there you're gonna hear everybody yeah
baby oh my God he was doing the Hot 100
Fest on his days off that's what that's
what type of Victorious run he was
having like did you hear what I said he
was doing the Billboard Hot 100 concerts
and [__] like his one-offs were crazy so
you obviously you grew up out in here in
L.A right for people who but but you you
how did you end up in Atlanta uh College
okay so where'd you go Clark Atlanta
okay so we know where you're from
obviously because you say it all the
time on 16. oh see except I'd like to
point out too that the first time that
you and it was you [__] Mack and was it
Sharp
yeah when he came on oh my God my God it
was classic bro I was just so wildly
entertained by like the on hood on 6-0
and like yo homie guys Papa's in prison
you guys are just mentioning people's
names and I'm just like this is the most
wild ganged out
but see people don't see that side of me
because I switch it up but like people
that I've been ganging with that's like
our our lingo that's like no I I mean
and that's why it was just and it was so
funny because like you were just here
like like the way like [__] Mack was
talking about like catching fades in
prison and you're like you know 6-0 he
got hands like I saw him in County right
Jesus Christ
yeah we was living because like we was
in stores like that before like now we
go to jail we would be like oh they're
like stars like the police know you
celebrity so they try to put you away
because you might have an influence or
people might want to get at you just to
show off type [__] whatever you can't
really Escape it I mean I'll probably
sign the waiver they probably end up
snatching me up to take me up there
anyway yeah what I'm saying because
it'll be too much controversy with me or
like I mean yeah so uh
we was on the main line we really was
thugging like you know what I'm saying
we eating with we fighting we doing
everything together yeah in the county
they always say that county is like the
worst place yeah it's the worst and so
let me get this straight because you
don't go outside every day right you
don't have a regular program the food
and in County isn't the LA politics are
still intact as to where if you go to
prison the politics swish a little yeah
so in County you squabble your enemies
like if you see somebody who's a like an
OP or whatever yeah yeah you guys end up
in prison together y'all might be
together yeah because if you're a [__]
you're a [__] of blood you all gonna be
together it ain't just no because it's a
race it's a race thing in prison right
yeah it's really a respect thing like if
somebody disrespects you then you got
all all action at the fade stabbing
whatever but if everybody keep it
respectful is yes everybody's a gang
member I know it's like it's gonna be
people from every Hood so if you're
gonna keep tripping on every year then
you're gonna everyone you're gonna die
yeah yeah I felt really bad like when I
saw money signs way pass away man in
there I was like [__] like see I just
found out he was a non-affiliate though
that's what I'm saying like he seemed
like he was just a good kid who just
ended up getting locked up yeah so what
it was when they put that pressure on
him he was standing he was standing on
business and it's like it's nobody there
to back him because he's not from a gang
so they know he got money and they
thinking that he's showing off just
because he's a rapper they the only
thing they have left to do is to do some
[__] like that instead of embracing me I
mean like be happy because yeah I mean
because I'm assuming he was in general
population yeah he was he was is it
because I always say like dude if I ever
God forbid had to go to like
County Jail I'm figuring out a way to go
to [__] PC I'm like slapping
put me in the hole pause
I don't want to be around nobody yeah
they gonna love you man it's good that
ain't that I went to jail I went to jail
once for one night
and somehow while being there
bro like I'm like in the holding cells
in Arizona
[__] six dudes just throughout the
day just walk by and recognize me and
I'm like
they're like why are you here and I'm
like oh no
I thought you were in a world where
nobody knew kid everybody knows I'm
using my sneaker as a pillow yeah at
your lowest with a little tissue roll on
top of it toilet paper
I didn't eat any of the food hell no I
was like I don't want to take a [__]
you're not you're not doing none of that
for at least three full days especially
your first time like come on man but
yeah with like you're famous though so
you go high power
me high power is like we're suigniting
everybody was that okay that's what
we're talking about trying to go to jail
that's where a Soulja Boy was that you
you you're in like a one-man sale that's
all yeah give me the one man yeah but I
don't want to go yeah nah let's point
that out I'm not going I don't either
that's what I'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm not going back either that's out
yeah I mean so you were in college
um you while you're in Atlanta you end
up linking with everybody out there is
doing doing you know yeah doing what
they doing shout out to PeeWee who's a
legend yeah man shout out a long way man
one of the most Mister don't speak he
won't talk he don't do interviews or
nothing I mean he did the blad one but
it was yeah you know yeah he answered
questions the right way and now yeah
yeah yeah now nobody would interview
because I was trying to no not not will
interview but nobody wants like desire
to say because you're not gonna get that
none of them know it let's just talk
about like you know food or something or
yeah food videos yeah